Pyro's Paul and I am professional
quizzing
I don't think you'd be exaggerating to
say that the top three quizzes in
Britain might just be the three most
knowledgeable human beings I've ever
walk the planet Pat Gibson who's a
former world champion that all told me
once that he's got falls upon files
about famous water polo players and it's
never come up ah that's the difference
being you and me I know what I've
decided that why that's my limit I
recently found out that Anton Chekhov's
nephew won an Oscar nomination his role
in the film Hitchcock film spellbound do
you share it and therefore when it comes
up and a quiz everybody gets it right
was it go I remember Paul put that on
Facebook the other day well do you keep
it to yourself I'm choosing the
alternative way of mentioning that only
on this YouTube video I can't picture
things people talk about memory premises
but for me it's all words and numbers
now revenge it were the Graduate in 1987
1987 was the year that New Zealand won
the first Rugby World Cup about revenge
there'll always be conspiracy theories
about the show was 8 times 7 and
automate what sort of food Oh chase what
colors of frog what kind of frog oh yeah
invested in an Aussie girl before
don't worry a lot of people they love
being photographs Oh nicely done so
before we were so rudely interrupted by
Z go Chris I challenge you to do a wrap
of the following three subjects the
execution of Mary Antoinette Shakespeare
and the life of a seagull amazing a
visit last week on was French Revolution
which Mary Internet featured it which is
fine I can I can tell I can totally
tackle it again
in different ways it will be it'll be
harder that's pretty
so the execution of marionette
William Shakespeare's first date and the
life of a seagull lovely let's do this
yacht yeah it's no hesitating no falter
and Vulcan like Spock let me put a
little head on a chopping block
royalty with a big hairpiece take up
from the mortal coil giver the release
year never forget your head cut off
Antoinette put it in the Bekaa can you
feel it yet does the brainstem get seven
right they're taken to the guillotine
remove from your chair cut your head up
today like your name is Jane Grey
everyone in the streets hip-hip-hooray
but in a French accent will in their
mustaches people get him blood up to
their galoshes cuz it spurts it out from
the arteries taking all the spinal fluid
out with these draining into buckets
parading it round everybody hear the
French Revolution sound revolving like
the Year 365 days every single year of
birthdays of the craze now we got this
it grew so near st. George's Day
birthday of Shakespeare and maybe affect
the you can provide was he born on the
day that he also died did that happen
was there their symmetry although if you
die on the day you're born it doesn't
make sense to me that would be like a
stillbirth or miscarriage it don't make
sense the airy had a marriage to the
lady he left the second-best bed but
people know that the bed that instead to
sleep in you meet Tom seemed at love
with ease over there people like I
cannot believe it's his birthday so make
no mistake he writes Hamlet Macbeth and
then eat some cake he's like
hip-hip-hooray
on this birthday 16:16 did that whole
sway was that the day that he's died and
perished he da here we go yeah I'm
accomplished less thing that I do yeah
like back at home on my bookshelf
Jonathan Jonathan Livingston Seagull
that's the book about one in here over
here in Brighton on the seafront you can
see these on the seashore
I'd be like see girls what you good for
coming to the window speaking in it was
there with this kind of cheeky grin in
the day it's like I need I feel in the
mood I want to go out and steal some
child's food going over there and making
a scream swooping in picking out
stealing a scream
it was so nice to have to be able to go
here's the facts I think I know is that
okay cool